So whatever you believe the truth to be about
the death of Jeffrey Epstein, there's a totally
separate issue, which is why do so many Trump
insiders end up having connections to Jeffrey
Epstein.
And quick disclaimer, anything even remotely
touching Jeffrey Epstein is instantly demonetized
by Youtube.
So please consider supporting the show directly
so that we can keep covering the stories we
want to cover, not having to worry about whether
they will be monetized bubble or not.
Um, Jeffrey Epstein died in his jail cell
on August 10th of an alleged suicide under
what are strange conditions we can call them
and I don't need to go all conspiratorial
the way in which he was found the injury.
Um, something about it doesn't sound quite
right to lots of people and we may just never
know the exact truth about what went down
there.
Okay.
The background of that story has mostly been
like the story that, um, uh, has been prevailing
in the media.
But there's another story which is that it's
not just Trump himself who's linked to Epstein.
You might remember we had that video of Trump
and Epstein at a party, uh, in the 90s, I
believe it was where Trump and Epstein are
standing there together looking at and sort
of evaluating the attractiveness of different
young girls.
And of course there's much more serious allegations
behind that as well.
Uh, it's not just Trump.
There are also Trump insiders connected to
Epstein.
There is a growing list and this latest one
is truly bizarre.
So Donald Trump's treasury secretary is Stephen
[inaudible] and Steven [inaudible] name appears
on a legal document for a company owned by
John Luke brew now, who's an associate of
Jeff Jeffrey Epstein's.
So you've got Epstein.
His associate is John Luke Brunel, John Luke
Brunellos Company, next management corporation
listed Steven Manoukian as a quote state point
of contact for the corporation.
This is another between Epstein and Trump.
This time via Steven Manoukian and Brunello
himself, by the way, has also been accused
of sexual assault and rape and of getting
girls for Jeffrey Epstein.
Now obviously immediately the media went right
to the treasury and said, why is Stephen [inaudible]
name listed here?
Why is he listed as a representative for John
Luke Pernell's company?
Treasury spokesperson said, it's quote, not
clear why Minutian was listed and that minutian
has no recollection of meeting John Luke Brunelle
in his life.
How strange is that?
Minutian is listed, but the Treasury Department
says that it's simply erroneous, but as usual
you sort of have to read between the lines.
Let's take a look at the statement from the
Treasury Department where they say, secretary
minutian never served in any official capacity
in next management corporation, never did
any business with, nor knows either of the
Brunello brothers and never had any ownership
stake in next management corporation or any
related entities.
Secretary Minutian had no knowledge whatsoever
that he was listed as a point of contact at
an address he's not familiar with for a company
that he's had no dealings with.
That listing was clearly an error.
Now, I'm not pretending I know the truth of
this.
I really don't.
This, it's bizarre.
I don't know the truth of it, but what I do
know is that I recognize what we call weasel
language.
When I see it.
If you look at this statement, he never served
in an unofficial capacity.
It's not denying that there could've been
an unofficial capacity in which he served.
He never had an ownership stake in Brunello's
company.
Of course an ownership stake is not necessary
to be in some way involved with the company.
He didn't know that he was listed as a contact.
Well a that is a very different thing than
there is no reason whatsoever for him to be
listed as a contact.
He just didn't know it.
Uh, much like the others surrounding Epstein
Bruneil disappeared from public view after
Epstein was found dead in August.
Uh, and it's just yet another one of these
bizarre data points that links back to Donald
Trump and connection.
So the practical question at this point is
what can we hope for what Epstein is dead?
What is it that we can hope to get from the
entire Jeffrey Epstein thing?
I think that there are three things.
Number one, we truly definitively need to
try to find out the truth about Epstein's
death.
I'm not optimistic as I said that we're ever
going to know that to the full satisfaction
of those who find something strange about
the circumstances.
The story is extremely odd.
It's difficult to fully believe, but okay,
that would be number one priority.
What are the real circumstances of Epstein's
death?
Number two, we want to find out the full truth
about any Trump involvement up to and including
the fact that Trump was accused of raping
a girl who was 13 years old at the time at
Jeffrey Epstein's Manhattan Condo.
We want that exposed to the fullest possible
extent.
And then number three, Epstein's dead.
But Epstein didn't work alone.
There were many people involved in Epstein
being a predator.
And the third thing I can think of that would
be a priority would be for all of those people
to be discovered, investigated, prosecuted
when appropriate and held responsible.
So we'll be following it yet.
Another just very strange data point.
I think that that's the way I would say it,
uh, related to Jeffrey Epstein and the many
connections to Donald Trump.